c'est l'anniversaire de Lily
grand-maman lui offre une carte cadeau
d'un montant de 25 dollars cette carte
est particulière elle est utilisable
dans tous les commerces d'un centre
commercial donné Lili range sa carte
précieuse tellement qu'elle l'oublie
pendant près de deux ans lorsqu'elle la
retrouve elle court à sa boutique
favorite du centre commercial pour y
dépenser son 25 dollars rendu au magasin
la douche qu'elle reçoit est froide pour
ne pas dire glacer la caissière lui
apprend qu'il ne reste que 5 dollars sur
sa carte pourquoi parce que des frais
d'inutilisation de deux dollars 50 par
mois ont été débités de sa Carte Cadeau
à partir du 16ème mois suivant son achat
est-ce légal oui
la loi permet d'imposer ce genre de fait
seulement pour les cartes cadeaux
utilisables dans plusieurs commerces
comme par exemple dans un centre
commercial donné cependant le montant de
ces frais doit être inscrit à l'endos de
la carte morale de l'histoire n'attendez
pas gardez vous